thanks Norman for that effusive
introduction it's really a great
pleasure to welcome Timothy Garton ash
who is a professor of European studies
at Saint Anthony's College at Oxford a
senior fellow at the Hoover Institution
and author of seven books a member of
the European Academy of Arts and
Sciences he's received the order of
merit from Germany Poland and the Czech
Republic and I have to say most
important from my perspective but I
don't really know the answer he has an
honorary degree from st. Andrews and the
question is do you get access to the old
course if you get an honorary degree if
so I'm actually truly truly envious know
you could have bargained for that
probably though and most importantly I
think in terms of his intellectual
history and record it's not only
exemplary in a kind of normal way but he
was one of the very very few people to
understand what was happening in eastern
and central Europe in the 1980s and who
actually got it right and actually
foresaw in a very insightful why what
was to unfold with the end of the Cold
War he's written a new book on European
American relations he's going to speak
today about a new beginning and what we
can hope is actually that your insight
and accuracy meant in the 80s is
actually replicated in terms of what you
see is a possibility for future
relations and cooperation between the US
and Europe so Timothy Garton - it's a
pleasure to have
so thank thank you very much for that
very kind introduction and it's a great
pleasure to be back here I've actually
just at the end of a two and a half week
tour which was mainly on the East Coast
and rather eccentrically I've flown
across to the west coast for about 12
hours before going back to Oxford which
may sound illogical but actually
Stanford is my home from home and really
has become so and so it does make sense
to come to the home from home before
going home
and I'm very grateful to the European
forum to the Institute to Norman a mark
in particular for arranging this lecture
and indeed of course to the Hoover
Institution for bringing me here every
year now my title is a new beginning
question mark what the United States can
do with Europe now I would have to say
and this title was of course concocted
before Tuesday November the second and I
would have to say in all honesty that
the question mark has I think got a bit
larger since Wednesday November
preferred that is to say it is
self-evident and this is not in any way
a political statement but it is a
self-evident that it would have been
easier to talk about a new beginning
with the president Kerry I think that is
self-evidently the case but clearly we
start from where we are my subtitle what
the United States can do with Europe now
um I I thought a bit about the
preposition one night I said what the
United States can do for Europe nah
or what the United States can do to
Europe now or about or against but I
decided to stick with with but that in
itself can be read two ways you could
say in the familiar phrase you know what
you can do with Europe and it has to be
said that I think there have been some
people in the can't Bush administration
who have used the word rather in that
spirit and in particular and this is I
think new have been of the view that you
can afford to ignore Europe that Europe
is of secondary if not tertiary
importance to the interests of the
United States which I want to argue as a
mistake but I also want to use the word
within the much more positive sense of
what we can do together now I'm going to
proceed is roughly high preceding the
book that's to say in the first part of
my remarks I'm going to talk about I'm
going to make an analysis of this crisis
of the West do what I call history of
the present the crisis of the West which
became acute over the Iraq war but is
still I think Withers and then in the
second part I'm going to try and be more
prescriptive as I do in the second part
of the book and answer comrade Lenin's
question what is to be done first the
analysis we talked about and the
analysis has to I think very much to
start with the world not just with
Europe in the United States we all talk
about the post 9/11 world I think the
world in which we live is defined by two
911s the first is the 11th of September
2001 the fall of the Twin Towers in New
York but the other is 9/11 written
european-style
with the day before the month the 9th of
November 1989 the fall of the Berlin
Wall the 9/11 of hope that preceded the
9/11 of fear and cursed enough I think
that the deeper causes of this crisis of
the West actually have to be traced back
to the first 9/11 to the fall of the
Berlin Wall in the end of the Cold War
even the moment of triumph are the seeds
of the disaster and I think the effects
of the end of the Cold War in
telegraphic brevity are to firstly in
they obviously Europe in the United
States are no longer held together by a
single clear common enemy
in the center of Europe in Germany in
Berlin the Red Army the Soviet threat
and the Soviet threat was the was not
just the glue it was the cement of the
transatlantic relationship of the Cold
War West it whatever the difference is
in the Cold War it brought us back
together again every time a former
British Foreign Secretary recently
remarked to me Tim you know if only we
had Brezhnev back he sighed
which is a British point of view they're
not I think a Polish one the second
effect at the end of the Cold War it
seems to me is that Europe finally lost
its centrality to world politics which
it had had arguably for at least 400
years and which geopolitical centrality
had in a way been artificially restored
despite the self-destruction of Europe
between 1914 and 1945 had been
artificially restored in the Cold War by
the fact that the conflict of the
superpowers was focused on Berlin and
Germany in Central Europe
lost and gone no longer the central
theatre world politics and indeed
particularly viewed from Washington
Europe can look increasingly marginal to
the United States from policy concerns
so there's I think of the two structural
changes that underlie the crisis of
relations between Europe in the United
States and I think any analysis of where
we stand now has to start by looking at
the world we're in a completely
transformed world now in trying to
describe that world my own view is it
the war on terror as a simple shorthand
for the world we're in is very
inadequate is one-dimensional and in
some respects misleading it's suggesting
as it does in analogy with the First
World War the Second World War
even the Cold War I do believe that one
of the major challenges of our time is
the combination of terrorism's I
emphasize the plural terrorism's weapons
of mass destruction some of which can be
carried in a suitcase and the existence
of rogue or failed States I believe that
combination is a new kind of threat
which defines the politics of our time
and as so often actually advances in
military technology produce a kind of
quantity and qualitative change in in
the politics but I think it's only one
of the great challenges that define our
time in the book I list a number of
great challenges the list is not
exhaustive I call them
the new Red Army's let me mention just
for one is the modernization
liberalisation eventual democratization
of the hole wider Middle East notably of
the 22 members of the Arab League
amongst whom there is not a single not a
single democracy something which is a
vital interest to Europe which is just
next to all secondly the rise or perhaps
more accurately the Renaissance of the
Far East after Japan India and in
particular China it seems to me that we
are so used to assuming that most of the
most most of the wealth and most of the
power resides in the West that we
sometimes forget that it was not always
so and will not always be so because
after all it has been so for about 500
years but the fact is of course if you
go back seven eight nine hundred years
then huntington's alternative
civilizations particularly the Islamic
and the Chinese worlds were both in most
respects more advanced than European
civilization and now if we look at the
trends the extraordinary dynamism of the
Far Eastern economies particularly India
and of above all China and we look ahead
and I know obviously that many things
but many are slipped that many things
can intervene to slow down these trends
but if we look at the trends it seems
probable that in 20 or 30 years time
China in particular will be a world
power of such size and and strength that
it will really transform the geometry of
world politics and that is a challenge
equally to Europe in the United States
and I'm really just listing these
challenges without we could talk about
the more on discussion the divide
between rich north and poor south the
truly shaming fact that a half of
humankind lives on less than $2 a day
and that most of the next billion who
are likely to be born as well population
grows are going to be born into poverty
and not into riches and finally the
undoubted scientifically established
fact that the surface of the earth is
warming at an unprecedented truly
unprecedented rate and the very high
probability I put it no stronger than
that the very high probability that
human agency particularly greenhouse gas
emissions our greenhouse gas emissions
if I may say so particularly your
greenhouse gas emissions the United
States is the SUV among nations are
contributing to global warming and we
are already seeing the effects in terms
of a climate change the summer of 2003
by the way the sum of the Iraq crisis
was the hottest summer on record for 500
years now you could add other challenges
to that list we could talk about AIDS we
could talk about Russia but my essential
point here is twofold
firstly I would challenge anyone in this
room to show me how in any of these
areas the vital long-term interests of
Europe and the United States differ in
any significant way in any significant
way our interests are either common or
coincident or at the very least
compatible and secondly I would
challenge anyone to show me how any of
these great challenges of our time
can be successfully addressed without
the joint and coordinated action of
Europe and the United States and I
believe I could demonstrate that
compellingly in each of the cases I have
mentioned and perhaps we can come back
to that in the discussion so those are
my two key points about looking at the
world we're in that essentially coolly
analyzed our interests are clearly
overwhelming at common and that none of
these great challenges can be tackled
without joint actual cooperation between
Europe in the United States and as I say
I hope we can explore how in detail in
in the discussion yet very large numbers
of people on both sides of the Atlantic
clearly don't see it that way
and we have clearly a great divide in
terms of all these disclaim attitudes
approaches what are called values we've
had a lot of talk about values in the
United States over the last two weeks
many claims are made about diverging
European and American values in the
transatlantic surveys you find that
large majorities of both Europeans and
Americans believe that the other have
different values Europeans believe that
of Americans and Americans believe that
of Europeans this view is of course
famously summed up in Robert Kagan's now
famous or infamous phrase Americans are
from Mars Europeans are from Venus now
one of the things I try to do not one of
the things I do in this book is to
demonstrate um I believe conclusively
that it isn't so and I believe that is
an empirical statement not a statement
of prescription or wishful thinking it
is an empirical statement and I have a
lot of empirical evidence to show that
actually our systems both political and
economic our societies our attitudes our
values are much less different than we
believe in aggregate for example
everyone says oh Europe has these
overwhelming welfare states and the
caricature of the United States follows
as a sort of Darwinian capitalist
Drummondville it's very interesting I
went back and looked at the proportions
of federal spending in the United States
since 1945 military spending as against
social spending broadly conceived
including healthcare medicare medicaid
education veterans and so on 1945 2%
social spending 89% military the other
percentages or of the other categories
at the end of Clinton Clinton's second
term 62% social spending 16% military so
complete flip to 89 to 62 16 and the
projection is that even after the huge
hike in military spending under this
administration at the end of 2004 the
proportion will still be 65 percent
social spending to 20 percent military
spending and as the baby boomers as we
know come up to retirement so the burden
of social spending the burden
the health care system will become
overwhelming in other words we have the
same problem values these famous values
some of you will know the World Values
Survey which has been mapping values for
something like 30 years they produce a
very interesting map which I will
produce at the back of the book the
Englehart values map some of you may
know this which attempts to chart the
values on two axes we could talk about
it in more detail but in discussion but
the basic point is what you do not get
is one clear coherent set of American
values and one clear coherent group of
European values what you get a clusters
of countries Catholic Europe Protestant
Europe post-communist Europe and the
english-speaking countries these are
Englehart four clusters Britain is of
course closer to the United States than
it is to Sweden let alone Romania but
actually France in its values
empirically tested is closer to the
United States than it is to Sweden let
alone Romania so it simply is not the
case that you can define European
identity versus American identity on on
the basis of measured values but as
important looking at this
characterization of Americans from Mars
Europeans from Venus and many aspects to
this as important is the fact that the
truth is that what we face is not one
Great Divide down the middle of the
Atlantic Europe America what we face is
a story of two divided compliments the
United States as we've just seen in
recent weeks but as in fact many surveys
have been picking up for some time is
quite deeply divided blue America
Red America actually on many of the
issues of values of social justice of
priorities for government action and
attitudes to foreign policy
multilateralism versus unilateralism
divided on many of the issues that
Europeans regard as defining us that's
to say but another way if you
disaggregate blue and red America you
find that on many of these issues both
domestic and foreign blue America is
actually much closer to most Europeans
then it is to red America not on all I
don't want to simplify but on many
issues blue America closer to Europeans
than to red America which of course in
sense is one of the charges made against
for example Bill Clinton and for example
let me give you one recent example of
that the German Marshall Fund had a
survey of transatlantic trends
transatlantic survey one question was is
military force the best way to win the
war on terror
more Americans answer yes and Europeans
but if you did see a great blue and red
Democrats and Republicans then what you
find is less Democrats answered yes than
the French so the French were more from
Mars than the Democrats and is it
perhaps that actually it's Republicans
who are from Mars and Democrats who are
from Venus I've been very struck I
actually have a web site out of this
book free world web dotnet in which
people can continue the debate and I
invite you to visit it it's a very
interesting debate and what's so
striking about it is that the fiercest
polemics a not between Europeans and
Americans they're not between French and
Americans they're not between French and
Brits they're between Americans and
Americans
this is where it gets really sharp
Europe too is divided divided in many
ways across many lines between countries
between classes between generations but
above all divided in one great argument
which is what I call the argument
between euro Atlantis ISM his most
eloquent spokesman is Tony Blair and
which argues that we need a strong
united Europe but as a conscious partner
to the United States and what I call
euro goal ISM his most prominent
spokesman his reaction arc which argues
that we need a strong united Europe as a
rival superpower to the United States
the polite term for that is of course
multipolarity and it was very
interesting to see immediately after
bush's reelection how both these two
positions were immediately articulated
by the two leaders of the camps Blair
rushing off to Washington to reaffirm
the transatlantic partnership and
jacques chirac saying this and I quote
to give you a sample of how its
expressed this was his immediate and
really first public reaction to the
election I quote it is clear that Europe
now more than ever has a need the
necessity to strengthen its dynamism and
unity when faced with this great world
power I let's build a rival superpower
and the point of our multipolarity
is not incidental because one of the
most for me worrying aspects of what
Chirac has been up to is the game he's
been playing with China which seems to
me really quite shameless and quite
grotesque he has literally painted the
Eiffel Tower red that is to say when the
Chinese President came to visit him in
Paris if you remember the Eiffel Tower
was illuminated in red and on
the Chinese president he subsequently
been to Beijing made no criticism of the
human rights record of the Chinese
regime essentially endorsed mainland
China's position on Taiwan without
reservation and said that he thinks the
EU should lift its arms embargo on arms
exports to China without essentially any
conditions either relating to human
rights or to Taiwan and in return he got
a few trade contracts and poked
Washington in the eye which were his two
purposes now what we see here is thus
the advancing shadow of a new great game
of power politics in the Triangle China
Europe United States and David Shambo is
actually a great expert on China has
gone so far as to talk about a China
Europe axis that I think is a bridge too
far but nonetheless the advancing shadow
of a game in which were put it this way
in the 1970s Henry Kissinger played the
China card against the Soviet Union
today China is playing the Europe card
against the United States and Chirac and
others have enabling him to do that so I
think that is a very alarming
constellation now let me turn and I'm
coming to the close of my first part of
my analysis of the history of the
present let me turn to the present on
the new beginning with the question mark
I wrote an op-ed before the election in
which I argued that it seemed to me
probable unfortunately that the
reelection of President Bush would
considerably strengthened the euro
goalie's tendency in Europe at the
tendency I've described and I'm afraid
to say that despite
some very significant gestures that have
been made by the administration um and
we'll come back to that in a moment I
see that happening already
I believe the Bush reelection has put
wind into the sails of the euro go list
tendency in Europe and I would go so far
as to say and this can only be a a hunch
that Jacques Chirac for example was not
altogether unhappy at Bush's re-election
because I say in some sense it
strengthens his position and I'm afraid
to say that I believe that despite the
gestures of goodwill that are being made
at the moment if one looks at the really
difficult set of issues that are on the
agenda between Europe in the United
States from Iraq through the very
difficult issue of Iran and how to stop
that regime developing nuclear weapons
to relations with China and there's
difficult question of the arms embargo I
mean there were plenty of possible
crises there and I wonder very much
whether the new beginning will in fact
long survive another crisis between us
and I fear that um the the reaction in
Washington to a year ago least gambit on
one of these issues would be to do what
the Bush administration has done in its
first term which is to say actually we
don't want to work we don't want them to
need to work with the European Union as
such as our preferred partner why bother
we will pick and choose we will
cherry-pick we will choose our
individual partners among the powers of
Europe the Brits have a loyal or is rely
on them the poles the Italian so long as
you have Berlusconi and great Ally
thought we had the Spaniards but
mysteriously Spain somehow switched from
being new Europe to Old Europe overnight
as it was out of an election but
nonetheless a sufficient Coalition of
the Willing can be found in other words
what Richard Haass a moderate Republican
former head of policy planning in the
State Department called disaggregation
or what the ancient Romans called DVD
Emperor
divide and rule in Europe and this in
turn if the administration did revert to
that practice whether one how a man
wishes describe it cherry-picking
coalition's of the Willing divide and
rule that would of course greatly
aggravate and offend large parts of
European opinion and would therefore
further strengthen the euro goalies
tendency so I fear and this is the end
of my analysis that we face not just a
possibility but I would argue I fear the
probability of a further downward spiral
in the transatlantic relationship in the
manner I've described that's the end of
the analysis that's as far as I can go
with the history of the present let me
turn now to an attempt at prescription
to the question what is to be done even
in this quite difficult situation it
seems to me that if the the new Bush
administration wants to change the
dynamics of the relationship I'm led by
Stanford's own hoover's own dr.
Condoleezza Rice as a new Secretary of
State
and to work against the trends I
described there are two key things that
need to happen or at least two key
things or two suggestions that I would
make one is that given these very deep
suspicions in Europe about American
policies of divide and rule the
administration would start with a very
clear and emphatic statement perhaps a
presidential trip to Brussels and a
clear and emphatic statement that the
year that the United States wants to
work with the European Union as a whole
and the United States considers as it
has done from most of the paid since
1945 that European integration and its
success is in the American national
interest I think that message would be
enormous ly helpful in Europe now one
thing I recount in the book is a very
interesting meeting that I and a couple
of others had with President Bush in May
2001 but before 9:00 before his first
trip to the to Europe and I got a
telephone call in my office in Oxford
one afternoon and a voice said them this
is the White House here could you come
and tell the president about Europe 145
on Thursday so I said well I do have a
lunch but I'll I'll try and change it
and then they flew me over I have to say
coach class and we had a fascinating
I'm more of a turn-on and we had a truly
fascinating conversation and one thing
of many that I will never forget was a
moment when the president you know new
in office new to the Foreign Affairs
broadly speaking looked us in the eye
and said do we want the European Union
to succeed and when my British colleague
and I and in fact interesting enough the
only two Europeans present were Brits no
French air Germans no poles when my
British colleague and I said very
emphatically that we certainly wanted
the European Union to succeed and we
hope that the United States would too
the president said oh that was only a
provocation only provocation well some
provocation it seems to me that it's
hard to imagine that any earlier
American president between 1945 and 2001
would have asked the question in that
frontal forum do we want the European
Union to succeed that is to say the
premise of American policy would have
been that in principle we do want the
European Union to succeed we have some
problems with particular aspects of it
and that I think was reflected in the
subsequent policy of the Bush
administration so that this very
emphatic strategic statement visible for
all to see we want the European Union if
succeed we want the whole of the
European Union as our transatlantic
partner would be of great importance
incidentally it has a tactical advantage
that you then have to kiss and make up
with Jacques Chirac or Gerhard schröder
because you don't have to get a Paris or
Berlin you go to Brussels and you
embrace the president of the European
Commission mr. Barroso and Javier Solana
both of whom are iberian euro-atlantic
cysts they're good partners and then you
embrace the assembled heads of Satan
government of the European Union and
NATO the second thing
I would do if anyone were listening to
me would be immediately and quite
decisively to broaden the agenda seems
to me if you're the United States and
you want help in Iraq and the Europeans
to get tougher on Iran the one thing you
shouldn't do is just ask Europeans for
help in Iraq and to get tough on Iran
because you get the answer no broaden
the agenda to the whole pallet of issues
on which we do have these compelling
strategic common interests in the
enlargement of freedom and by all means
speak the language of the enlargement of
freedom Iraq Israel Palestine Iran
Afghanistan Darfur
the thematic issues that I'd mentioned
the wider Middle East managing the
emergence of China as a world power the
Doha round climate change two reasons
for broadening the agenda one tactical
the other strategic the tactical reason
was rather nicely expressed by some you
will know of the british scholar
diplomat robert cooper who actually
wrote the european security strategy
which is quite an interesting answer to
the american national security strategy
and robert quoted the other day a remark
of janmani janmani as he said if you
have a problem you can't solve enlarge
the context and i thought this was a
wonderful remark so I emailed Robert and
I said Robert could you answer fantastic
I want to quote it could you um tell me
where Jean Monnet said it and Robert
email back in silent and turban bass but
someone told me that someone told him
that Jean Monnet said it but said Robert
and I love this I'm morally certain
that money said it more or less answer
whether the Monet or Robert Cooper or
someone told me the other day actually
James Madison in the Federalist Papers
it's a great piece of diplomatic advice
enlarge the context but the other reason
for doing it is it is simply
substantively correct this is the truth
strategic agenda as I tried to lay out
at the beginning for Europe in the
United States and we should face it
squarely now before throwing is open for
questions and comments and discussion I
want to say one last thing in conclusion
which is is I've been talking a lot
about challenges dangers threats and it
seems to me the whole language in which
we talk about world politics since 9/11
has been a language of dangers and
threats and fears in a sense between the
first 9/11 and a second 9/11 we had a
language of hope and opportunity now we
have a language of dangers and fears and
many of those dangers are real but I
think it's important to realize that
beyond that we do actually live in a
time of great opportunity and the
subtitle of the British edition of this
book is why a crisis of the West reveals
the opportunity of our time
Random House said that was too
complicated for America and said the
American subtitle is America , Europe
and the surprising future of the West
but simpler the Canadians by the way
took the American edition identical in
every respect but they change the
subtitle back for Canada and why crisis
of the West reveals the opportunity of
the time because I argue that like an
electric storm it does indeed reveal the
common interests that we do in fact
and it reveals the opportunity and the
opportunity is this in 1974 before the
revolution of the car nations in
Portugal freedom has counted 39
democracies in the world this year
Freedom House can say a hundred and
seventeen democracies in the world out
of one hundred and ninety two sovereign
states and the truly dramatic and
unprecedented increase we could argue
about the tally I make it 116 because
they can't Russia and it seems to me
extremely difficult to argue that Russia
today is in any meaningful sense of
democracy I think actually the more
compelling figure is not that tally of
one hundred and sixteen or seventeen
democracies which includes electoral
democracies and not in any way less
liberal democracies but their figure of
eighty eight free countries which i
think is quite well-documented
eighty eight free countries in which
some 2.8 billion people live let's say
nearly half of humankind lives in free
countries there has never been a time in
human history this is I think a simple
factual statement where more people have
been more free and where indeed we have
more possibilities of the further
enlargement of freedom we don't face
great totalitarian bloc's nuclear-armed
totalitarian blocks in the way that we
did throughout the Cold War and I think
we should take heart and courage from
that from understanding that opportunity
this lecture was set to mark two
occasions one is in a sense the election
of the 44th President of the United
States the other is the 15th anniversary
of the fall of the Berlin Wall the 9th
of November this year
now I just want to take you back for a
moment in conclusion to what it felt
like a few years before the fall of the
Berlin Wall and take you into the
kitchen of a tiny apartment in a
battered office block in Warsaw and a
couple of dissident friends of mine
their friends were in prison Brezhnev
was in the Kremlin they lived in a
communist police state censorship
repression and there they were rolling
out on the kitchen table with a squeegee
a squeegee
ink press the first number of a samizdat
journal 1978 and they wrote in the first
editorial of the first number
our objective is an independent
democratic free Poland 1978 that seemed
like aiming your bicycle at the planet
Mars 12 years later it came true the
walls came down the impossible happened
and it seems to me if they were capable
of that vision and that courage and that
politics of Hope politics is the art of
the impossible we might have a little
more vision and courage and refused what
I call the illusions of impotence the
illusions of impotence because what we
face above all now in our politics
particularly in Europe in the United
States is not any more concrete walls
but what I call the mind walls the walls
in our heads the walls of prejudice and
ignorance and selfishness and the
opportunity we face is nothing less it's
not just to be clear about it it is not
to reconstruct the old Cold War West of
Europe in the United States that's
finished that's done for it won't come
back again it is to move forward from
the Old West to what I call
host west a wider community of
democracies including countries like
India and Taiwan Latin American
democracies which have not belonged
historically and culturally to what in
American universities used to be called
once upon a time western civ a post West
a much wider and widening Community of
Democracies in other words and this is a
central argument of my book and with
this I end the opportunity we face is to
move from the free world of the Cold War
and now anachronistic and in some sense
I think compromised term if you remember
Jean Kirkpatrick considered one point
that Pinochet's Chile belonged to the
free world ie the anti-communist West
the opportunity we face is to move
forward from the free world which will
never come back again towards a free
world to adapt Winston Churchill never
in the history of grammar has the shift
from the definite to the indefinite
article be more important thank you
[Applause]
okay we have time for questions and
comments I ask you to keep them brief
and straight and we have microphones
here so that you can be heard we would
ask you just to come to the microphones
if you have any questions
hi my name is Bruce I am with the
Institute I'm from Europe and one thing
that I've missed in your in your talk is
the role of public opinions in Europe
you describe them actually in your in
your book particularly in the run-up to
the war in Iraq and how these public
opinions have basically taken on a
majority part different position than
that of their governments including in
countries like Britain and Italy and
Spain under the snar and so so when you
when you go out around Europe and talk
about this issue what do you tell what
you tell them as opposed to what you
tell to politicians and and and
academicians who see things apparently
differently and then a second quick
question because you mentioned
Condoleezza Rice do you expect that with
her at the State Department things may
change in a direction or another thank
em thank you yeah um I mean I tell
readers in Europe exactly what I told
you and it's quite interesting actually
this book has already come out in German
and it's coming out in Italian Spanish
Portuguese Italian Spanish French or
polish all the major European languages
in the next few months and each
discussion is very very interesting the
debate is very interesting but the
position on public opinion is a bit more
complicated that's to say the
overwhelming majority of European public
opinion was against the war on Iraq as
conducted by the Bush administration
with a few European allies starting in
March 2003 that is absolutely true right
but if you look at the surveys by the
Pew Research Center and the German
Marshall Fund on others the picture is
more complicated European public
opinions are well able to distinguish
between their attitudes to the Bush
administration and their attitudes to
America so that it is not the case that
there is a majority for a euro go
----list position---- - cor yeah there
was a majority against the Iraq war but
not for the euro goal is position in
fact if you look more closely you will
and that I believe there is a silent
majority for the euro Atlantis s
position although that remains to
protest it and I would very much welcome
it if from this administration and the
State Department under under complete
arise were to test that proposition I
mean as you will see I think the United
States should take the gamble it is a
gamble that you can win the whole of the
European Union to be your partner in
this great endeavor rather than just
settling for a few individual European
states there's I mean there have been
quite a few significant gestures that
the president said in his first press
conference that you know in in effect he
want to be up in Union exceed wanted to
work with European Union they've now
announced that there will be a trip in
meet soon after the inauguration to
Brussels you know there is a certain
breakthrough on Iran as a division of
labor between us where the American hard
cop and European soft cop we shall see
how it goes I think there was a real
opportunity there and I'm sure that
condi rice understands that opportunity
but as I say the test will come in the
first crisis and I suspect that crisis
will come sooner rather than later
Mr Bond okay okay I think Mike we're on
and there's actually a hopeful
development which are keenly aware of
which is the three European contact
powers who've been dealing with Iran
seem to have made a breakthrough
agreement in persuading the Iranians to
cease the enrichment of uranium and
suspend what I think most observers
think is a covert nuclear program and if
this holds I really think it may wind up
averting what could have been a real
catastrophe both globally and for
euro-american relations all over again
which would have been a preemptive
strike probably using Israel as a proxy
against the Iranian nuclear facilities
and this you know I'd love your reaction
to this is this kind of a glimmer of
hope of what can we expect and more
generally you know what does this say
about the initiatives that Europe might
take acting as a union that might draw
the Bush administration in to take this
gamble because I think you phrased it
exactly the right way what else might be
done on specifically on that first
opportunity you mentioned of
democratization in the broader Middle
East on the Middle East peace process
and on some of these other initiatives
that would I guess there's the one way
to put it is to appeal to the better
angels within the Bush administration
Thank You Larry um a good question I
mean on Iran I would have said a week or
two ago that Iran was likely to be the
next Iraq crisis it's getting likely to
be the next crisis of the West and
sooner rather than later this is a
glimmer of hope but glimmer is exactly
right and it's an interesting case
because it shows you that
his needed is not always the classic
division of labor in which Europe is a
soft crop and the US is a hard cop
Europe offers carrots and the US office
sticks because actually what's needed in
this case is it Europe we waves a bigger
stick and the United States waves a
bigger carrot I mean that seems to me
the way forward is that we have a bigger
joint stick in other words European
countries are prepared to take it to the
UN are prepared in the end to impose
sanctions but also that the United
States is prepared to take the risk and
offer the carrot of full normalization
so that's where we should go
whether both sides are ready to go that
place I'm I wouldn't bet on it
and second breakthrough is of course
Israel Palestine that needs to be
mentioned and again and it will be a
foolish person who bet much money on
achieving these settlement between
Israel and the Palestinians but
nonetheless there is another glimmer of
hope a moment of opportunity and that is
of course it has to mentioned an issue
which has enormous potential for
producing bad blood between Europe and
the United States enormous potential
because Palestine
I witnessed the huge anti-bush
demonstration in London when he went to
visit Tony Blair and Trafalgar Square
and vast with them and incidentally a
mullah crying
Allah Akbar from the bottom of Nelson's
column a memorable moment what Nelson
would have made it I didn't know
but the biggest banner at that
demonstration was a huge huge banner
which said free Palestine right and on
the other hand obviously a particularly
interesting Israel from the United
States and if things go wrong then it
very very rapidly descends into those
accusations that we have seen already
over the last few years accusations of
European anti-semitism as a main motive
for backing the Palestinians which i
think is incorrect and accusations of
you know whether were Zionist conspiracy
among the neo cons and so on say it's
potentially a very damaging issue what
the European Union should do it is very
clear to me now
we should say this president is a very
odd kind of conservative he's not a kind
of conservative that we know in Europe
he is on the one hand Jacksonian yeah
something we don't really have in yet
but he's on the other hand Wilsonian
this is a man who really talks
passionately about the spread of
democracy the promotion of freedom yeah
and his press conference with tony blair
was absolutely extraordinary because he
ended up saying i really believe in
democracy because I believe that
democracies don't fight each other
Immanuel Kant george w bush's becoming
Immanuel Kant say the opposite of what
Robin Kagan said do you know Europeans
of the Canton's and the Americans are
hugs in now it's the other way around
but you know there is a genuine
wilsonian and indeed Kantian element
that and our response should be to say
we absolutely agree with you about the
ends this is the most important thing we
need to do and this is what we can
contribute you can't do it on your own
you can't do it just with military force
we Europeans have decades of experience
and democracy promotion in Central and
Eastern Europe we know how to support
opposition groups we know how to do
independent media we know how to support
civil society we know how to use trade
and credit as linkages we know how to
open our markets as an incentive we know
how to bring young people from the Arab
world to our universities we know how to
encourage millions of people to come as
tourists thus opening their eyes to the
experience of the West this is
complicated
it can't be summarized in one sentence
but let's put it on the table and I
think that is exactly what Europe should
do next if you yes I would like a to
hear your view on the effect of radical
Islamists
in Holland France London Germany
Brussels Antwerp etc um it's a good
question
um couple of points first of all I think
the degree to which French policy was
dictated by the motive of appeasing the
Muslim population in France is
overstated I've no doubt it was a
subcutaneous element but you know there
are plenty of other French reasons for
behaving as France did without that and
to go behave like that in many ways when
at a time when there weren't millions of
Muslim immigrants in France I think that
particular factor has ever sated
secondly it is much easier for an
extremist mullah to get a preaching job
in London or Paris than it is for them
to get a preaching job in Istanbul or
Ankara I mean it's a curious fact about
our free societies that that we make it
easy for extremist preachers come to our
that societies um thirdly I think it is
one of how we make Muslim immigrants
feel at home in Europe is one of the
biggest challenges the biggest
challenges in front of Europe the fact
is that the politics of immigration have
already nearly destabilized the party
systems of Western Europe lepen
Klim for tuned Haider the list goes on
now in even the UK Independence Party
the politics of immigration of nearly
destabilized old established party
systems with relatively low levels of
immigration certainly compared to the
United States because of our aging
population because of the pressures from
Meniere's we're going to get a hell of a
lot more immigration so how we cope with
that how we don't build up these
extraordinary alienated populations in
the Bunya of Paris and the outskirts of
Madrid who are in fact which are in fact
the breeding grounds of the terrorists
right it is no accident that some of the
people who flew into the World Trade
Center became radical Islamists in
Hamburg and of course the Bombers and
Madrid Moroccans living in Madrid and
there's a particular difficulty here I
mean I as you will see I don't have an
easy answer but there is a particular
difficulty which is in a turks sometimes
say you're not taking us in because
you're a christian club misunderstanding
if europe at some point says no to
Turkey it won't be because we're a
Christian club this book is were a
secular club because the religion of
Europe is secularism
our belief is non belief that's what
unites us and it seems to me it is the
case that it's actually more difficult
in a sense for religious Muslims to feel
at home in a set highly secular society
in a curious way than it is for them to
feel at home in a more religious society
like that of the United States I think a
believing Muslim can feel more alienated
in Hamburg or London than in Kansas
curiously enough because as a religious
person you are surrounded by other
religious people many of whom believe in
the same God so I think it is a hue
huge challenge for Europe one of the
biggest to make Muslim immigrants feel
at home good evening Rasheed see I'm a
student in the history department I have
two related questions for you my first
deals with the challenges that you posed
early on to us to point out if we could
indicate anything that wouldn't indicate
a conflict of interest between Europe
and the United States and all these were
long-term criteria and I think the
solutions that you posed bear that out
in the sense of shifting toward the
European Union away from bilateral
relations and then broadening the
context I want to press the question of
agency somewhat here basically all of
your your suggestions have revolved
around common cooperation between both
Europeans and Americans I'm curious
where you foresee the shift from the
short-term point of view that clearly
dominates now to a longer-term point of
view coming who is going to initiate the
shift obviously this is a little bit of
futurology but where does this actually
start happening and the second question
deals with the current nature of foreign
policy with respect to the EU even with
the new constitutional treaty bilateral
relations still seem to be very much
dominant in terms of foreign or
international dealings with the European
Union member states looking even at
let's say the Czech Republic or Poland
in general the post communist states
especially are strong on the bilateral
relations even questionnaires Keyes
comments after Bush's elections you can
bear that out
I'm curious if you see the maybe the
post communist countries as being the
first step towards shifting away from
bilateralism toward community operations
and if not then how do we expect the
United States to treat the EU as a whole
if the whole is really just an ad hoc
entity thank you
yeah very good questions briefly the
difference between a statesman or woman
and politician is precisely the
difference in someone who thinks about
the long term and someone who only
thinks about the short term one of our
problems in Europe at all in all
together in the last five years is that
we've had politicians rather than
statesmen Allstate's women and I think
Tony Blair in some sense is the
exception who proves the rule as to say
his someone who does have a long term
strategy I think the right long term
strategy but his tactical maneuvering
has actually subvert adhesion strategy
right so we need better leaders it's
always easier to say but I think we do
um now very also they're justified quest
about the EU I mean the fact is the
degree to which the EU gets at least
coordinated positions is often
underrated over here
um you know 80 percent of issues there
are coordinated EU position but they're
the easy ones of course or the important
ones like climate change hotel is a
common position or the Doha round
they're not the really difficult ones
the Constitution provides for more
coherent foreign policymaking mechanism
but whether the Constitution will go
through is another question nonetheless
you know there is some movement in that
direction now I would say two things one
is the United States has always been a
major influence on the process of
European integration so actually you can
influence this process right if if the
United States keeps saying not just
repeating the old Henry Kissinger will
you say Europe which number should I
call which by the way I don't in
Kissinger ever said like many of these
famous is like Jean Monnet as many of
those most famous quotations in history
but I think he likes to think that he
did and but um if the United States says
please give us
we can call our default position is
always that we want to call Solana right
that's our default position on any issue
first choice work with European Union
come up with your common position and
we'll go with that understand that if
you can't come up with a common position
then we'll have to work with a smaller
group of states and in a lot of cases
like Iran you will end up with smaller
groups contact groups that seems to me
just fine so it's a two-track strategy
for the United States which would be
very hopeful it's even I want to ask you
a question about France and ask it in
the most forceful way your premise is
that if we look at these major issues
there are no differences between Europe
and the United States but I would say if
you look at the Middle East and you look
at develop third world development you
can spin out a story about why France
would have a position antagonistic to
the United States and even the rest of
Europe if you want to play a role as a
major power France is more able to play
that role if the Middle East is divided
if the palestinian-israeli situation is
not settled and if you look at france's
role in francophone Africa for instance
that role is more prominent if those
countries are still linked to France not
particularly developing and still mired
in a kind of quasi colonial relationship
and the question is if you look at the
French a leech which is in my view
unique in the Western world in which you
have a relatively small cadre of people
who went to the same schools running the
country their personal interests really
would deteriorate if these problems were
solved especially the third world in the
Middle East problem compared to their
position if the problems continue to be
exacerbated so the question is if we
look at France in particular is it
really the case that the United States
France share the same purposes or even
France and the rest of Europe it's it's
it's an excellent question
um which goes to the the definition of
interests doesn't it and if we say that
the French national interest is to be
seen at a dramatic figure on the world
stage
and that he says it were the lasting
national interest of France and the
first national interest of France then
you might well be right that would seem
to me well a serious misunderstanding of
the French national interest now I
actually think that there is a there's a
French problem and there's a specific
Chirac problem
this man is extraordinary and the the
head of another European state said to
me um he said when I first met Jacques
Chirac he thought he was the Gould's
grandson now he thinks he's the girl's
father
and it is absolutely extraordinary
hubris is his second name and I think
he's truly and something about sitting
in the Alizee for too long I mean it
happens to all our leaders sooner or
later but in the alizée perhaps more
than most
he truly seems we has lost touch with
the reality of French France is well
understood national interest yes
so the question then is is the rest of
the French foreign policy elite in the
same place and I think the answer is no
I really think the answer is now I have
a lot of intensive contacts with these
famous a nark people like Jill and
Ronnie for example major foreign policy
thinker they see it they see that French
policy is on a hiding to know where that
actually the notion that you can
actually unite Europe around the policy
of being a superpower rival to the
United States is absolutely for the
birds because Europe will always produce
its own divisions and Washington they
only hyper power will always be able to
exploit those divisions you cannot unite
Europe against the United States so it's
a hiding to nowhere maybe a few
particular interests in Africa in the
phone call phony but oh by the way I'm
told that even in the Cote d Ivoire this
is face a defiant boiled France even in
the Cote d'Ivoire France is now very
unpopular and a journalist who was there
told me that in there in that country
there was a great demonstration with
people holding up banners saying please
America come and save us even in the
Cote d Ivoire so you know this is a
country which has a major problem
because it's on the losing side of
history they have I think a very
impressive elite which has in part
grasped that and doing things like teach
could see Oslo in English working in
business in English working in the
European Union in English adapting in
rather remarkable ways Nicolas Sarkozy
the possible successor to shark not an a
knock by the way not from the classic a
lead
very interesting on this score a realist
a pragmatist he's made some quite remark
is strikingly critical remarks about
share acts foreign policy and the belief
that you can call the shots in Europe
simply with Germany as you're only a
partner so you know I agree with you
there plenty of grounds for skepticism
but I also think there are significant
figures in the French political elite
who were capable of ultimately of
realism
what if Nixon's henchmen said don't
listen to what we say watch what we do
and I submit this is true of the first
Bush administration and my question is
to give credibility to whatever Bush may
say in Brussels what can and should the
United States do or not do thank you I
am I think some extent I try to address
that in the talk um I think you go down
that strategic agenda and you say this
is what we're going to do on climate
change no one expects the United States
to sign Kyoto the Congress won't allow
it but there are plenty of things you
can actually do to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions without signing Kyoto this is
what we're going to do in the Doha round
this is where we you know in the first
year of an administration where we can
actually risk doing something unpopular
this is where we are going to cut our
agricultural subsidies cotton subsidies
and so on this is where we are going to
lower our tariffs what are you de you
going to do this is how we're going to
take the israel-palestine peace process
forward those will be three very big
things very big things very important to
Europeans where you would be bringing
something to the table that Europeans
actually want and then you can say and
now what we need is a following kind of
help in Iraq as we're in a mess and what
we need is what we were just talking
about in relation to Iran that you
actually sacrifice some of your
short-term commercial interests in order
to produce the big stake in relations to
Iran and so on I think that's how the
conversation should go
yes just a comment in connection with
what to do when you're faced with a
problem you don't know how to solve the
famous stanford mathematician george
pólya and is book how to solve it said
when you can't solve a problem there
must be an easier problem that you can't
solve either and you should first look
at that and then you'll learn how to
solve the harder one thank you first of
all I want to thank you very much for a
very lucid and and eye-opening
presentation and I want to ask two
questions the first relates to the
analytical part of your talk and the
second to the prescriptive with regards
to be analytical mean it seems that
increasingly European foreign policy is
defined both by the internal integration
process that is happening in Europe we
see sort of enlargement as foreign
policy and we see really the emergence
of the EU defining itself as a community
of identity of a distinct identity a
community of values my question I mean
this is associated with the notion of
soft power as Chris Patten recently put
it sort of soft power with a with a hard
edge with the development of CFS B etc
do you see that as a path dependence and
as a structured direction of European
foreign policy which is perhaps leading
away from American foreign policy you
haven't addressed that that aspect in
your presentation with regards to the
prescriptive do you think that a
concrete problem that the United States
may invite Europe to cooperate with it
on could at this moment be useful we
have another you know four more years of
bush probably another four or five more
years of Blair there's the issue of Gaza
which is an issue of State Building and
nation-building if I've ever seen one
as you say Europe has enormous
experience in capital which it has
gained over the last 15 years in central
Eastern Europe in democratization in
institution-building could you see the
American administration turning to the
European Union and saying let's do this
together
offer Israel closer political
integration in exchange for withdrawal
from Gaza and the West Bank offer Israel
a stake in the single market of the
European Union in exchange offer
membership in the OSCE offer membership
in the Council of Europe help the
Palestinians
build the kind of institutions which the
quartet we forget about this but you
know a common u.s. EU coordination
mechanism has a fairly coherent view
about what needs to be done do you think
that that would be helpful at this point
thank you for for both parts and the
latter is a very interesting suggestion
um let me answer you in in this general
way that I'm they struck by how outside
this room it seems to me most Americans
don't get the European Union they just
don't get it it's very mysterious and
confusing and obscure and and one reason
I think is it um is that you have to
think about power in a different way one
of the problems that seems to me with
neoconservative the Robert Kagan
description of the relations in Europe
in America the heading which was if you
remember power and weakness American
power European weakness is it it is
predicated on premise on a
one-dimensional definition of power
let's say military power hard hard power
and in that measuring America is
all-powerful
and Europe is weak economic power the
European Union is in many respects the
equal of the United States this is not
soft power it's a category mistake to
say that economic power is soft power
the European Union next year and China
will be each other's largest trading
partner in front of the United States
the European Union blocked the merger of
two great American companies General
Electric and Honeywell that's power
economic power then we do have soft
power the power to attract so much so
that virtually all our neighbors want to
join the European Union and the European
Union has a say peculiar kind of power
what I call the power of induction which
says to all our neighbors if you do this
that and the other if you make a market
economy if you respect certain standards
of human rights and minority rights and
the rule of law and so on then somewhere
down the road you can join the club with
enormous benefits and this is power that
the United States does not have and will
not have as far as I know Mexico and
Canada are not applying for membership
of the United States anytime soon and
wouldn't be offered it and so Europe is
the opinion is getting bigger in the
United States is not and that is one of
the key contributions that we can make
to this common transatlantic strategic
agenda I would argue that saying yes to
opening negotiations for EU membership
for Turkey in mid-december is at least
as large a contribution to fighting and
winning the war on terror as anything
we've done in Iraq if not larger to show
that an Islamist government with a prime
minister who five years ago we're saying
our minarets are our bayonets yeah it is
now working in the context of a secular
state and doing everything you can to
get into European Union that's a huge
contribution okay suggestion on Israel
very interesting um promised a
membership would be extremely difficult
but this quite hard to imagine but there
are things you can do short of
membership to encourage that association
so yes I take that very much on board
and I hope that and Americans will in
time understand this different kind of
power which is you know not a Cadillac
it's more like a hub a shis border it
grows very slowly a number of different
plants and yet it grows and just in
conclusion
um I know normal of course has worked a
lot on that great term farm policy
strategist Josef Stalin and you will
remember that Josef Stalin once said how
many divisions has sapote well the Pope
won in the end
and so if one asks how many divisions
has the European Union I might like to
think again thank you
[Applause]